the idea where oregon's going in the
direction of legalizing all the drugs
you know what what they're thinking
about doing is is that the right
direction i'll read
exactly what they're doing organ votes
to decriminalize all drugs
uh uh for uh mental health treatment
first state law of its type makes
maximum fine for possession of any drug
a hundred dollars and increases
treatment which means cocaine
if i have cocaine i'm kind of a hundred
dollar fine with results from 76
of precincts reporting early wednesday
morning 59
of oregonians approved measure 110 the
drug decriminalis
decriminalization referendum and 56
voted for measure 109 uh according to
associated press
the campaign in favor of measure 110
raise a 4.5 million dollars the 109
raised 5.7 million
what are your thoughts about what oregon
is doing with drugs is this the right
direction we're going
with legalizing every drug not
legalizing just the finance 100
right so it's it's a it's not
decriminalizing it completely yes
it's reducing the penalties for it with
in the articles i've read uh say that
their reasoning
is to focus more on rehabilitation okay
i'm in favor of rehabilitation i don't
think
legalizing or reducing penalties is the
way to go about that
people say well there it will give them
more incentive to get into rehab
why why is it going to give you more
incentive
what we're going to see when you
legalize marijuana
we we recognize marijuana and this might
be my personal opinion or law
enforcement opinion
but i think a lot of americans would
agree with this
it's a gateway drug so i think back to
when i was a kid
you know i'm a little kid in tennessee
uh somebody stole a beer out of dad's
refrigerator
we all sat around took a drink of beer
because it was cool it was that that
peer pressure thing
tasted like crap you know at that age
but you thought you were cool
and so what's the next step well
somebody stole a bottle of wine out of
dad's refrigerator so we took a drink of
that you know
and that's not so bad so then we're you
know we're graduating into whiskey
into liquor it's the same principle with
narcotics people trying marijuana like
that's not so bad
you know it makes you hungry afterwards
i've been told just so you know i've
never smoked marijuana but
i've been told it creates uh what they
call the munchies you know
preacher's boy taking beer away from
that i mean your dad was drinking
my dad oh i i thought you were talking
about your dad i'm like listen that's a
pretty
uh uh aggressive church if pastor comes
i mean those messages got to be powerful
messages
my dad was a southern baptist minister
he ruled by the rod
you know he always said he was a legit
straight oh
i grew up a very different lifestyle
than most people you know you look at
those numbers in oregon
right 55 went for it i mean are you
kidding me who believes that
who literally thinks that's a good idea
is it just young people that are saying
yes just drug
people that do drugs here's the other
question that's why this thing with city
power so important
if they can manipulate the presidential
election if in fact it did happen yeah
what about some of these propositions
some of these other things in other
states why couldn't they you know skew
the results on that as well i mean
something like legalizing drugs or what
they want to do in seattle or in
washington is legalize misdemeanors
essentially
that one came out yesterday that just
brings more chaos to society
which there is one faction that wants
that
so that the trickle-down effect from the
potential
of this fraud on these voting machines
just goes so deep
well and you look at marijuana and it's
you know people say what's it's harmless
no it's not people say it's a victimless
drug well
a couple months ago i did a little spot
for a tv station in l.a where seven
people were murdered in
riverside california in a marijuana grow
site they didn't take their money they
didn't take their drugs it was a
retaliation attack i mean
to me it looks like it's probably
competition yeah that was the one at
that party right that outdoor party
no no this was a private house and there
were seven people in there that had been
maintaining this grow site
is that victimless when you've got seven
murders that's not victimless
it's ridiculous but now you look at the
we're looking at the hard drugs we're
looking at cocaine heroin
methamphetamine opioids holy cow it's
now
it's now acceptable to have possession
of illegal opioids
you know another thing that's not even
being talked about very much
is the counterfeit medications come to
the united states many of which are
laced with fentanyl
so javier and i the last two years we've
been working with a group called
partnership for safe medicines
we've been on capitol hill twice once
for uh the house side once for the
senate side last year we went spoke to
the american legislative exchange
conference
which was legislators from all 50 states
right here well
down the road in austin texas you know
we we received a positive reception from
them but i was a little surprised that
so many of the state legislators were
unaware that this is a problem
people say well we need to be able to
buy our medications from online canadian
pharmacies
talk to the canadian talk to the rcmp
there is no such thing as an online
canadian pharmacy
what they do the bad guys will ship it
in from pakistan china india whatever
countries that it may be originating in
it passes through china anybody can
create a website
we've got a website you know it didn't
cost anything very little to create a
website
and you can put you put a picture of a
maple leaf on there and this is what
we're doing
it's all bogus because it passes through
canadians to the canadian law
enforcement
or medical professionals have a
responsibility of checking the package
no it's just a pass-through country so
you don't know what you're getting the
counterfeit
the bad guys what they'll do is they'll
take the active ingredient out of a peel
if it's an opioid they'll take that out
and replace it with with uh with nothing
just leave the binders in there that
hold the pill together
so if you think you're getting cancer
meds you might be taking a placebo and
not know it
they might leave a little bit of the
active ingredient in there but you're
still not getting
what you thought you were right amount
that you thought you were getting right
right and then
if they put fentanyl in there oh my gosh
i mean you guys know it takes three
grains
three or four grains of not grams grains
think of a grain of salt that's enough
for an overdose
it's all prince died exactly so
i mean we're looking at what's the
latest numbers i saw
roughly 70 000 deaths from overdose
here in the united states 46 over 46 000
i think were attributed just directly to
opioids
and now in oregon it's okay if you've
got counterfeit opioids or you've got
opioids that you don't have a
prescription for
one of the most dangerous things in our
country and not just
oregon you know dc passed
have tentatively tentatively passed for
the psycho
psilocybin mushrooms the psychedelic
mushrooms to be legal
in d.c now i live outside of this maybe
maybe the politicians need to take some
though maybe they will come out with
some new ideas
bypassing marijuana going right to the
mushrooms aren't you oh i mean party
time
but here's my question for you i don't
even drink alcohol here's my here's my
question for you though
the way you started it you said uh we're
the number one country in cocaine
it's the cheapest it's ever been
wholesale prices are down which means
it's coming in more
and it's not a statistic we want to lead
in and he said you can go to any street
right now if you wanted to buy cocaine
you could right okay
fine so if you and i today wanted to go
on a project we had the camera crew
following us in a very low-key way to go
on the streets of dallas to see if we
can find cocaine
we're probably going to end up finding
cocaine we may need 30 minutes to an
hour but we're probably going to end up
finding cocaine
which may not be a bad project to put
mario and adam on just to kind of
get arrested be careful just let the
camera roll be careful
be very careful but but here's where i'm
going with it here's where i'm going
with that
the libertarian position many of the
libertarian position is
legalize all of it if you want to put
that on your body do it you know if you
want to kill yourself with it go for it
i mean it's not like you can't kill
yourself with alcohol
many people are killing themselves with
alcohol matter of fact up today there's
only been one person that killed
themselves with marijuana
uh on based on statistics but god knows
how many people have kept
killed themselves with alcohol right
what's the big deal if we legalize
marijuana what's the big deal if we
legalize these things it's not like they
can't get it anyways i mean yourself
said you can't get it so
if you can get it if we do legalize it
does it get rid of the drug dealers that
are out there i guess that's the
question
well we've legalized marijuana have we
gotten rid of the mexican marijuana
growers have we stopped the violence
not at all it's too lucrative a market
they make too much money in that
the and what's happened with the
legalized marijuana is the jurisdictions
where it's legal have taxed it so
heavily
it's more expensive so they can buy what
we call skunk weed you know they can buy
the illegally grown marijuana cheaper
so the market's still there but here's
the other thing should you and i
and tom should we change our morals and
our standards
for money i don't agree with that
when these people become addicted are
you and you and i who work hard for our
money who pay our taxes
we've worked hard all our lives i'm
retired i'm working as hard now as i
ever did
should we be responsible for creating
rehabilitation programs would it make a
difference would they have gotten the
drug regardless if it was legal or
illegal
well when it's legal people think well
if it's legal it must be okay it must
not be that bad you think that's what
they think because for me
even though cigarettes are legal and
alcohol is legal
i don't think it's good i mean i every
time i see somebody smoking cigarettes i
tell myself what are you smoking
cigarettes for
i mean we know at this point it's
terrible what are you smoking how many
more commercials do you need how many
more
you know how many of those things do you
need to see to say this is not something
i want to do i mean it's
family's being lost over cigarettes and
alcohol so you know
and if you choose to drink responsibly
let's just say you want to go have a
whiskey let's just say you want to go
have a cigar and a whiskey with friends
okay fine
but uh cigarettes are legal i mean you
remember the movie day
what's that one movie they did with that
one actor that played in uh in
one of these uh uh avengers movies or
batman spider-man movie
what's the spider-man movie um anyways
one guy plays a bad guy
in uh he plays a bad a bad guy in batman
i believe
and it's the story of philip morris how
he's going around telling people that
circuits are not bad for you it's okay
for you it's not addicting
and he's a phenomenal lobbyist
incredible lobbyist this movie
blew up because of how we exposed
philip morris's lobbyist how great of a
job they were doing going out there
convincing people it's not that bad for
you then eventually you have to put the
sign saying
if you smoke cigarettes this could kill
you you could get cancer etc etc
so if people are already going to get
their hands on it what's the difference
if it's legal or illegal
the difference is it's going to change
your lifestyle if you become addicted to
it
you can become a non-productive member
of our society no i get that what i'm
asking is but if i can get it
steve being if it's legal i have access
to it
if it's illegal i still have access to
it what is the difference
well i think when you legalize it it's
just so you've got people are saying
and and this has been proven with
marijuana you know i've always wondered
about it well now it's legal let me try
it yeah
becoming addicted to marijuana is is not
going to happen if you smoke a few times
heroin cocaine methamphetamine
opioids the chance for addiction can be
there with the first use
now people are going to argue about it
you're going to get a lot of negative
comments because i said that
go back and read the jurisdictional or
go back and read the researches
the reports that the met i had bonafide
cdc
or medical research paper not some group
that
yeah i think marijuana should be legal
because i want to try it look at
legitimate
studies and see what's happened
countries around the world have tried
legalizing drugs
with good intent but the truth is if you
go look at them it hasn't worked in any
country yet
you end up with more addicts you got
more people out there that are not
working you've got
you want people sleeping on your front
lawn trying to break in your house so
they can obtain money they say well if
you
legalize it then uh you know that will
cut down on crime
you still got to gain money to buy it
just because it's legal doesn't mean
it's free
you know i i here's a little unofficial
survey i don't see anybody smoking
cigarettes anymore
it almost makes me wonder how big
tobacco stays in business how much did
how much can you pull up how much
phillip moore's revenue was in 2020 so
far 2019
okay but i can't go a day without
smelling marijuana
without seeing people smoking now it's
legal in california but any you go for a
walk
it's weight on the weekends you're
smelling it everywhere you go to lax
and if that's the big new thing now
people smoking pot
outside of lax i smell it all the time
every single week
so holy moly
billion us dollars cigarettes
wow think about it they're spending way
less money on advertising so their
profit margins are probably way better
right i mean imagine how much they were
on every magazine you know billboards
they used to
spend so much money clearly they're
getting cigarettes into the hands of
people how much is a pack of cigarettes
how much is a pack of cigarettes today
what's the package would you guys know
or no i mean i have no idea
but type in what's the price of a pack
cause anybody knows the price of pack of
cigarettes if you're watching this
comment below obviously you're giving
yourself a way that you kind of know but
i guess i'd guess five bucks right so
let's do the math each pack of
cigarettes how many cigarettes does it
have can you go and do the math
tell me how many cigarettes in a package
okay 628 let's do the math here
let's do the matthew i'm actually
curious to know
so 628 um
divided by 20. 31 cents
figuring out how many cigarettes i just
kind of wanted i mean i
am such a he's looking for a new
investment 250 billion
cigarettes per year guys 250 billion
cigarettes smoked every year
250 billion man so so 250 billion
cigarette smoke if you took it down to
average of 7.7
what's 250 billion divided by 7.7
billion
if you just did it by 7.7 billion
you're talking about each person on
average smokes three point two
cigarettes per year
okay each person if each person is
putting children have you smoked any
this year
i haven't smoked any have you have you
never experienced cigars me too but not
cigarettes
a quarter of a billion cigarettes are
still being smoked per year
oh my god by the way if you're watching
this you're a
proud cigarette smoker and you're
willing to say
i smoke cigarettes proudly i know some
of you guys want to admit to it
but if you're a proud smoker of
cigarettes comment below and say you
smoke cigarettes i'm actually curious
isn't it unbelievable i don't understand
cigarettes that's the one thing i don't
understand imagine i understand weed
cigarettes right and to think that
people used to smoke on airplanes
30 40 years ago yeah i mean it was
everywhere now it's just not cool
anymore we see the old movies even in
congress
you're testifying before congress and
they're sitting there smoking a
cigarette they're in an open economy
well you know
biden wants to legalize marijuana across
the board
nationwide similar to the federal
minimum wage that they want to do across
the board they want to legalize
marijuana so
if you're watching this if you're
watching this you saw the little banter
that we have here
press thumbs up if you say legalize
marijuana
push thumbs down is if you say
absolutely not do not legalize marijuana
right now we have 334 thumbs up two
thumbs down so we'll see what's going to
happen with the difference there
with thumbs up and thumbs up i'm
actually curious what the you know
average viewer thinks
whether we should legalize it or not let
me say one more thing about marijuana
now
and again this is uh kind of odd coming
from you know i was a cop for 38 years
javier was also
if i don't believe that anybody
should live in chronic pain if you have
cancer whatever
the medical condition is it causes you
chronic pain legitimate
not not self-imposed but uh
or created in your own mind yeah
imaginary and if
if smoking weed relieves you of that
pain if psychologically you think that
relieves you the pain
quite honestly i don't have a problem
with it but that's medical marijuana
that's not
you know growing your own weed in the
backyard or going out buying skunk weed
from somebody out in the field
i just don't think that uh anybody
deserves to live in that kind of pain
and
we've had family members pass from from
uh cancer as well as
uh other illnesses so i know that's kind
of odd coming from us or
when i say uh some talk about javier as
well because we've had long discussions
about this
but legalizing these other drugs
including marijuana
i don't think is the answer what is the
answer well i think
i think we should do a much better job
at educating our
young people at the earliest possible
wage so i've got
five granddaughters now uh if i have to
scare the crap out of them at the
youngest age possible
to get them to realize how bad the
effects of narcotics are
i'm okay with that and i love my
granddaughters i'll do anything for them
but we need we need to do a better job
of educating we used to have the dare
program a past
yeah say no to drugs a past organization
did away with the budget was that nancy
reagan is that the
yeah yeah the education part is so
important it starts at home if you can't
train your kids by yourselves you're
screwed because and then what about all
these families
where the parents smoke marijuana
they're smoking pot so they're
experiencing it
throughout their childhood they're
seeing it it's accepted their friends
are doing it
me personally i just here's one message
i preach
you're a loser if you do drugs and i
just stay with that with all three of my
kids and it's working so far
well you know dea has a program i'm not
speaking as dea because i'm retired
and i'm not an expert on this at all at
all but i'm aware of an initiative they
have called the 360 strategy
so people want to come in and say hey
law enforcement is your responsibility
stop drugs
one organization can't stop it it's so
prevalent in our society
so what they've done is 360 goes into a
city a high-risk city
and they bring every component of the
city together so you got your law
enforcement
your court system your politicians your
doctors your pharmacies your housewives
the faith-based community
everybody comes in and collectively
works to
come up with a solution to whatever the
drug problem is in their community
and they're seeing some successes is it
overwhelming success no but they are
seeing progress
so i think that's a pretty uh pretty
good operation i think whoever thought
that up in dea did a phenomenal job
coming up with the concept
but also i'm a big proponent of
self-acceptance and responsibility for
your actions
our society today has become so
permissive anything's okay
i mean it's just ridiculous what's going
on out there right
so but you know i knew if i did certain
things
i was going to pay the price with my dad
and i you know i knew what my
i did grow up in a rough upbringing
because of what was expected
but that was the bottom line i knew what
was expected and i knew what the penalty
was if i didn't live up to expectations
so why don't we have that now why is it
okay for you to go do everything you
want to do
when you're hurting other people you
know it's just
i'd like to see us get back to where
we're making good sound decisions and we
accept our responsibilities for a bad
decision
yeah i i i tell my kids the story my two
sons i sat him and i said you know who
the president is yes president trump
i said do you know his older brother no
who is he fred trump do you know what
happened to him no he died you know how
he died no from drinking too much
alcohol
he drank too much alcohol became an
alcoholic and then he eventually killed
himself you know who doesn't drink any
alcohol who president trump
why not it's a personal decision that he
made so the i go through that process
so then i told the story i think a
couple months ago
uh uh so we had some people over and we
have alcohol in the closet so she opens
it up in our nanny says yeah that's
alcohol
and my son comes up to me on my
seven-year-old he says daddy why do we
have alcohol in dallas if you say
alcohol kills people why do we have a
look how they hold you accountable right
right and my oldest son trying to
protect me says
dylan daddy has alcohol in the house in
case something happens you get a wound
to put alcohol on it
that's why
it's interesting you know how he thinks
about it
you